It was a marvel of the modern age, a ship its operators built as unsinkable.
On April 10th 1912, the RMS Titanic, crammed with over 2,200 passengers and crew,...
...departed from Southampton bound for New York.
For many on board, the voyage was an opportunity to escape poverty and create a new life.
For other wealthier passengers, it was an enjoyable social voyage.
The ship docked at Cherbourg and Queenstown in Ireland before the crossing to New York.
But just five days in early on the morning of April 15th,...
...the ship hit an iceberg, tearing a vast hole in her side.
Chaos ensued as Titanic began taking on water...
...and the crew and passengers scrambled for what few lifeboats there were.
Many left half full, leaving those trapped on board to their fate.
Just three hours later, the ship split in half and sank with 1,517 lives lost.
Just one hour later, rescue arrived for the survivors...
...in the shape of the Carpathia, a passenger liner.
The ship would become a legend, spawning books...
...and one of the most successful films in Hollywood history.
More importantly, it would also result in a shipping safety revolution which has endured to this day.
But the greatest legacy of the disaster is the memory of Titanic herself,...
...a name which conjures images of one of the most memorable tragedies in maritime history.